now the reason why I have graphs in the
middle of bottom trigonometric graphs in
the middle of all this is because what
we looked at on Tuesday was a graph so
remember right we took some time we
looked at the unit circle and we graphed
a function it was y equals sine X okay
now I'd like you to either if you've got
it nearby
refer to that graph or if you join have
a new bike just draw again it's getting
on take walk
you got your axes here and we went from
nought to 360 okay that's the part of it
that we drew so by the end of the lesson
we kind of got the shape we got the
shape right and that was kind of where
we finished so I wanted a few more
things about this okay yes sine X I'll
just put a few important angles on here
there's 90 there's 180 right at halfway
between 180 and 360 halfway between
those ears what's the angle 270 very
good whoops
and right at the end where we chose to
stop is 360 okay so a few things to know
the first thing is it's a smooth curve
okay to smooth in fact that's if you
recall that's what sign means it means
curved okay that's where it gets this
shape from that's where it gets its name
from rubber so it's a smooth curve and
um if you like me you aren't you started
off drawing these because I've drawn
thousands of these maybe tens of
thousands that's why my looks is so
heavy but when you begin it's kind of
hard to nail this shape so you might be
like trying to try to do some of this
yeah okay tada that's the basic shape
and that's not a bad place to start but
you can't finish there this is not a
curve this is about 15 curves okay you
need to present one maybe you want to do
this lightly in pencil and it go through
it firmly with a single line okay so
it's a smooth Jeb that's the first thing
and that's why it isn't important okay
the second thing is this curve right it
goes back and forth so these
particular spots at the top and bottom
okay you can notice it's a bit like if
you imagine like a um a rollercoaster as
it were going up and down right at these
spots here right it's likely going up
nor down right it's not like he is
really really steep you coming up right
here it's sort of like via the roller
coaster stops right it's not increasing
in height it's not rack rocketing down
it just kind of stops there right there
we have a word for that which you guys
might might have heard before which is
stationary right stationary means
something is not moving it stops as it
were okay so this point up here and this
point down the bottom right also you're
not going up you're not going down you
just kind of stopped we call them
stationary points okay
now this are putting this in brackets
because it's a actually a really big
important phrase that you will learn
more about into unit but it's sort of
just like a bit of a spoiler you'll
learn about that later on I just want
you to know that now okay by the way
it's stationary with an A as opposed to
stationary with an e which is this kind
of stuff okay
that was the second thing the third
thing I'm like you know this is curves
here I've got two of them right what's
really important is that these curves
are not semi circles they are not semi
circles right so I've seen lots of
people whose graph and it looks kind of
like he's my bad breath I'll get rid of
it and I'll replace it with another bad
graph these two halves they kind of look
like well he is one of them he's the
other okay so it kind of one looks like
now honestly you can do worse than this
right like that everything I showed you
before that's not very good this is a
little little cleaner at least but can
you see a semicircle right these points
in here it's exactly vertical right
exactly vertical but do you remember
that very first task when I said over
here is this enormous set of axes and I
asked you guys to give me points and we
drew it right it doesn't do this
vertical thing
there doesn't do it here it sort of
increases at this gentle rate again if
you want to picture a rollercoaster okay
rollercoaster czar gonna do this kind of
thing unless you're at that one they're
just gonna straight up and down it is
there's no vertical parts to it okay so
they're not semicircles right fourthly
again another important word I'm going
to introduce to you this graph is what
we call periodic periodic now what that
means is like you guys know what it
means when you say something to periodic
it's like okay this happens regularly
right now why does this happen remember
the unit circle okay when we got all of
these values from was from reading for
sine it was for reading the
y-coordinates like how high up and down
am i on the circle okay now you start at
zero and then you go all the way around
90 180 270 and then you wind back at 360
okay now if I kept going 360 370 380 390
450 blah blah blah blah blah you're
going around the same circle right so
you're gonna get the same values again
and again and again they repeat okay so
on your graph like all I've drawn is
noise for 360 but in fact it continues
it continues in both directions forever
okay
that's what we mean by its periodic it's
repetitive and it repeats every 360
degrees because that's how many degrees
there are in a circle so it's periodic
every 360 degrees
one more thing to note our last point
here can you see right because it
repeats and just goes up and down and up
and down by the way we have another word
for that you know it oscillates kind of
like an like a pendulum or high or low
tide or the height of the Sun in the air
in the sky rather as the seasons
progressed it oscillates up and down so
therefore it always stays within this
kind of range right never goes higher
and never goes lower unlike say micros x
squared it just blows up forever right
there's no point where you could say ah
there's the ceiling of y equals x
squared and it stops here you're in this
narrow space okay so this narrow space
we call the range the range okay now
range is an up/down word okay it's about
vertical things and the vertical axis is
y okay so we say it stays between
negative 1 and 1 that's what the Y
values do okay
so rather than saying because that's a
bit long and awkward to say the Y values
always stay between negative 1 and 1
mathematicians write this using symbols
to make it faster okay this is our
notation to say Y right it's always got
to be greater than or equal to negative
1 it's always above that but at the same
time it's always less than or equal to
positive 1 right it's above negative 1
it's below positive 1 and that's the way
we kind of tie that up in a neat bow all
right so these are a few things to know
about this sine curve